personhood the state of being a person
and a concept coming to a state ballot
near you this us midterm election voters
in several states will decide whether a
person is the person as soon as the
spermatozoan reaches the finish line aka
fertilizes an egg you could call this
cell a person or you could call it what
scientists do a zygote but to hell with
science person who is really about
abortion and a woman's right to have one
PS that right was granted by the Supreme
Court back in 1973 but the show must go
on if North Dakota passes measure one it
become the first state to protect life
at quote any stage of development and
Coloradans will decide whether to amend
their constitutions definition of a
person so it includes the quote unborn
ah the unborn kind of like the undead
except unable to walk and in Tennessee
voters could give lawmakers
constitutional free rein to restrict
abortion rights pro-choice advocates
around the country say laws like these
are about complicating criminalizing and
ultimately ending abortion at the state
level by calling as I go to person
abortion becomes murder even in cases of
rape or for a woman's health kind of
funny given these states don't take such
good care of the living Tennessee has
more minimum-wage workers than any other
state in the country and the personhood
of LGBT folks doesn't seem to matter
much there or in North Dakota gay
marriage is still illegal in both states
heterozygotes only please by the way the
death penalty totally legal in Colorado
and Tennessee cuz at the end of the day
while you may have personhood humanity
is still hard to come by one more
download the AG plus mobile app and join
the conversation available in your app
store now